the last time we heard from
world-renowned religious scholar Lily J
she was busy trying to convince her
followers that Muhammad is the holy
spirit but she accidentally ended up
proving that Jesus is the god of
Muhammad fun times but Lily wasn't
finished now she wants her fans to
believe that Muhammad is God and her
fans are too clueless to realize that by
agreeing with her they're all committing
the unforgivable sin of Sher let's watch
Lily insist not once but twice that
Muhammad is God she's asking chat GPT
about Bible verses that Muslims claim
are prophecies about Muhammad here's
what she comes up with all right chat
TBT what's next Deuteronomy 33:2 the
Lord came from SI and dawned over them
from sear he Shone forth from Mount pan
Deuteronomy
33:2 let's go go ahead and read the
verse before we get Lily J's powerful
commentary we'll start at verse
one this is the blessing with which
Moses the man of God blessed the people
of Israel before his death he said the
Lord came from SI and dawned from sear
upon us he Shone forth from Mount pan he
came from the 10, thousands of holy ones
with flaming fire fire at his right hand
so this is near the end of the book of
Deuteronomy God used Moses to lead the
children of Israel out of Egypt to the
promised land God said that Moses
wouldn't be allowed to enter the land he
would die instead Moses the man of God
blessed the people of Israel before his
death he said the Lord came from
SI who came from SI the Lord when you
see Lord Lord in all caps in the Bible
it's referring to Yahweh or Jehovah the
name of God some Bible translations keep
the name usually as Jehovah for instance
the American Standard Version reads and
this is the blessing wherewith Moses the
man of God blessed the children of
Israel before his death and he said
Jehovah came from Sinai and Rose from
seir unto them he shined forth from
Mount pan and he came from the 10,
thousands of holy ones at his right hand
was a fiery law for them but most
translations use Lord in all caps when
the name of God is used in the Hebrew so
who is the Lord in Deuteronomy
33:2 who came from SI dawned from Seer
and Shone forth from Mount
pan this is God indisputable right it's
obvious zero no
confusion now back to chat
GPT Deuteronomy 332 the Lord came from
siai and dawned over them from sear he
Shone forth from Mount pan who's the
verse
about God but according to Lily J it's
about three human prophets who's first
the Lord came from SI okay so we know
the prophet Moses got the Ten
Commandments on Mount si yes Moses got
the Ten Commandments from God at Mount
Si but that's not what Deuteronomy 332
is about Deuteronomy 332 is about God
leading the children of Israel from
Egypt to the promised land it's about
the Lord dawned over sea where's sea I
just read into it where is Sea C is the
south of Jerusalem and Jesus was in
Jerusalem busted where is
seir Lily J says she looked it up and
learned that seir is South
Jerusalem she says she looked into it
where where did she look notice for
everything else she says she gets chat
GPT to say it and you can actually tell
chat GPT to give Islamic answers which
is what she normally does and then she
pretends that chat GPT agrees with the
dawa script but here she doesn't ask
chat G GPT she just says where's sea I
just read into it where is Sea SE is the
south of Jerusalem and Jesus was in
Jerusalem why not have chat GPT
answer because even after telling chat
GPT to give Islamic answers she couldn't
get it to say that seir is South
Jerusalem chat GPT wouldn't sink that
low seir is not South Jerusalem you
could say that Seer is south of
Jerusalem as in way way south of
Jerusalem seir is in the area of the
there are two ways you could
find this out one you could look at a
Bible map here's seir way way south of
Jerusalem Jerusalem is north of this
entire map two you could look up seir in
the Bible tons of references you can go
all the way back to Genesis and read in
Genesis
323 and Jacob sent Messengers before him
to E saw his brother in the land of seir
the country of
Edom there are nine references to seir
in the Book of Genesis we know where it
is and it's a long way from
Jerusalem speaking of Genesis in two
previous videos I mentioned artsa boxes
these are boxes that ship straight from
Israel when AP and I were in Israel last
year we noticed that the shops in
Jerusalem were empty and AP as selfish
as he normally is asked if there's any
way to help several months went by and
someone contacted us and said that artsa
boxes are a way to help the local small
businesses in Jerusalem and Nazareth and
Bethlehem people sign up for quarterly
boxes artsa gathers items from local
shops and Charities spices snacks crafts
decorations soaps all kinds of things
and ships them out quarterly so you get
a new box every 3 months anyway in two
videos I mentioned artsa boxes as a
great way to get cool items from Israel
while helping the people who produce
them the awesome people at Arta were
happy that we were promoting their
products so they agreed to sponsor some
videos and I'm going to keep promoting
the boxes I'm mention them here because
the current box is the Genesis box it's
a Genesis theme of course if you're
watching this video a few months from
now it'll be a different box but now is
a good time to sign up they're not
expensive they're fun to open with your
family they make perfect gifts if you'd
like to start getting your artsa boxes
the link is in the description be sure
to use the promo code Dizzle to get a
discount now back to sear lots of
references to seir in Genesis you can
even look up seir in the book of
Deuteronomy the same book Lily J is
quoting plenty of verses such as
Deuteronomy 28 so we went on away from
our brothers the people of Esau who live
in seir the the people of Esau
live in Jerusalem Lily
J here's a particularly good reference
to seir judges 54 to5 Lord when you went
out from seir when you marched from the
region of Edom the Earth trembled and
the heavens dropped yes the clouds
dropped water the mountains quaked
before the Lord even sin before the Lord
the god of Israel who went out from Seer
the Lord all caps the mountains quak
before the Lord even SI before the Lord
the god of
Israel why does this passage say that
the Lord went out from
seir hold that thought so we know where
seir is but where is it according to
Lily Jay's Deep dive where's sea I just
read into it where is Sea SE is the
south of Jerusalem and Jesus was in
Jerusalem why does she lie and say that
Seer has something to do with
Jerusalem so she can pretend that the
reference to seir is about God sending
Jesus why would she be so desperate to
to claim that seir is about God sending
Jesus because she needs SI and seir to
be about prophets so she can claim that
pan is about Muhammad and then Mount pan
where is Mount pan Mount pan is
traditionally identified with the region
of the Arabian Peninsula specifically
around Mecca it's believed to be the
area where Ishmael the son of Abraham
settled this connection leads to the
interpretation that the verse May refer
to the emergence of Islam from that
region well
wow this is what I meant when I said
that you can tell chat GPT to give you
Islamic answers we performed a little
experiment live and asked chat GPT where
Mount pan is in the Bible let's see here
okay where is Mount
pan in the
Bible pres okay so yeah Lord is hubac
there there's the other one they use
habub 3 it's giv you passages it's not
um the Wilderness of pan Sinai Peninsula
uh oh everyone catch that she's she has
she has chat GPT set to give the answer
it's Mecca it's Mecca what does that GPT
if you don't say it no way there's no
way the chat GPT unless you manipulate
it will tell you that pan is commonly
identified as Mecca pan is in the Sinai
Peninsula it's a long long way from
Mecca in fact remember this map where we
found seir look at what's really close
by it's Mecca I mean pan you can find
these places on just about any map of
The Exodus because these were the places
the children of Israel went to or passed
by during The Exodus Sinai pan s
Lily Jay wants you to believe that seir
is in Jerusalem and that pan is
somewhere around Mecca so she can twist
this into a prophecy about Muhammad but
Deuteronomy 33:2 is about God not about
Muhammad why does the bible say that God
was in these
places well during The Exodus God
appeared to the children of Israel as a
pillar of cloud by day and as a pillar
of Fire by night as we read in Exodus
13 and the Lord went before them by day
in a pillar of cloud to lead them along
the way and by night in a pillar of fire
to give them light that they might
travel by day and By Night the pillar of
cloud by day and the pillar of Fire by
night did not depart from before the
people when God would lead them from one
place to another the pillar of cloud or
fire would move as an example here's
numbers 10 11 to2 in the second year in
the second month on the 20th day of the
month the cloud lifted from Over the
Tabernacle of the testimony and the
people of Israel set out by stages from
the Wilderness of Si and the clouds
settled down in the wilderness of pan oh
look Sinai and pan it's as if this has
absolutely nothing to do with Mecca or
Muhammad now that we know the locations
and now that we know about God appearing
to people let's revisit Deuteronomy
33:2 the Lord came from SI and dawned
from sear upon us he Shone forth from
Mount pan he came from the 10, thousands
of holy ones with flaming fire at his
right
hand is this about three prophets Moses
coming from SI Jesus Dawning from Seer
and Muhammad shining forth from Mount
pan no this is about the Lord the only
thing that could seriously be defended
here is that this is about Jesus since
many Christians believe that appearances
of God in the Old Testament were
appearances of the pre-incarnate
Christ but that's not what Lily J is
claiming I really like the wording of
this verse so it says the Lord came from
SI so Moses brought the Ten Commandments
that was like this beginning of this law
yes Lily J Moses received the Ten
Commandments but that's not what
Deuteronomy 332 is about it's about the
Lord just like it says dawned over from
sea dawned so what's Dawn Dawn is when
the sun rise the Sun comes and that
makes a lot of sense with Jesus's coming
He restored Faith He restored peace he
was the light of belief it makes a lot
of sense lovely thought but seir isn't
part of Jerusalem seir is the region of
the how are you going to
connect this to Jesus without lying and
sha forth from Mount pan sha forth Jesus
brought the dawn like the brought the
light and then Prophet Muhammad Shone
forth Mount pan is part of the Sinai
Peninsula not Mecca this has nothing to
do with Muhammad Lily J you just took a
verse praising God for guiding the
children of Israel out of Egypt and you
twisted and tortured it to try and make
it about
Muhammad completely insane what I really
like about this is that it brings the
all the religions together it's saying
hey you guys aren't separate you're all
under the same God you're all worshiping
the same Creator this verse really hit
me lovely sentiment once again nothing
to do with the
verse God is literally saying guys
you're all brothers and sisters in faith
why can't you get along it's just a
continuation I actually can't believe
this is in the Bible and no one's saying
anything like how can people not read
this and just be
overwhelmed well unlike you Lily J most
people who read Deuteronomy 33:2 would
read it after reading Deuteronomy chap
1 through 32 and so they would
understand what it's about and there's
no way anyone would ever start reading
at the beginning of Deuteronomy get all
the way to chapter 33 and conclude that
Deuteronomy 332 is about
Muhammad claiming that Deuteronomy 33:2
is about Muhammad is daah level insanity
and dawa clowns would never in a million
years actually read the book They're
quoting because as we've seen reading
the book destroys the
deception and daah is always
deception speaking of deception Lily Jay
isn't done yet okay okay okay hang on a
minute I just found okay so I just
searched in the Bible I find all the
verses that mention Mount pan okay
really you found all the verses in the
Bible that mention Mount
pan okay okay okay hang on a minute I
just found okay so I just searched in
the Bible I find all the verses that
mention Mount pan okay shouldn't have
been terribly timec consuming since
there are only two verses in the Bible
that mention Mount pan Deuteronomy 33:2
which we just went through and habach 33
which we're about to go through there
are lots of verses that mention Pan and
the Wilderness of pan but there's also a
particular mountain or mountain range in
the region of pan that's called mount
pan Lily J has already duped chat GPT
into giving the da deception about Mount
pan having something to do with Mecca
but watch what she does now I just found
another one this is just whoa listen to
this so it says the Holy One from Mount
pan his glory covered the heavens and
his praise filled the Earth so this is a
prophecy of a holy one coming from Mount
pan it is quite literally prophecy of
prophet Muhammad who else could this
possibly be about who else could this
possibly be
about well let's see what Lily Jay
deliberately cut out of the verse she
quoted look at Lily J's version of the
verse the Holy One from Mount pan his
glory covered the heavens and his praise
filled the Earth it's pretty strange
that our Muslim friends insist that they
don't don't deify or worship Muhammad
when they claim that verses like this
are about Muhammad Muhammad's Glory
covered the
heavens but Lily Jay left out the
beginning of the verse here's how she
reads the Bible the Holy One from Mount
pan his Splendor covered the heavens and
the Earth was full of his
praise what happens if we don't
deceptively edit the
verse God came from Tean and the Holy
One from Mount pan saah his Splendor
covered the heavens and the Earth was
full of his praise His brightness was
like the light rays flashed from his
hand and there he veiled his power who
is this about God who is the Holy One
this is still talking about God his
Splendor his praise His brightness his
hand his power
time for a crash course on the book of
habach it's only three short chapters
you can read it in five minutes unless
you're a ly J fan in which case it might
take you five
weeks the book is about the prophet
habach questioning God's justice why
does God allow evil people to go on
doing evil things instead of punishing
them God answers habak and says no one's
getting away with anything God will
punish evil people but God has his own
timeline we get to chapter three and
habach prays a prayer of habach the
Prophet according to shago that's some
sort of musical term oh Lord I have
heard the report of you and your work oh
Lord do I fear in the midst of the years
revive it in the midst of the years make
it known in Wrath remember mercy so
habach says he's heard things about God
and God's work and he asks God to revive
it and to make it known then habach
Recaps some amazing things God has done
he's reminding people and himself that
God knows what he's doing God came from
teeman is that about Muhammad and the
Holy One from Mount pan
Salah is this about Muhammad no habak is
referring to the exact same thing we
read in Deuteronomy 33:2 this is about
God appearing to the children of Israel
and leading them out of Egypt and to the
promised
land his Splendor Muhammad's Splendor
covered the heavens and the Earth was
full of his praise Muhammad's praise His
brightness Muhammad's brightness was
like the light Rays flashed from his
hand Muhammad's hand and there he veiled
his power Muhammad veiled his power
before him before Muhammad went
pestilence and plague followed at his
heels Muhammad's heels he stood and
measured the Earth Muhammad measured the
Earth he took and shook the Nations
Muhammad shook the Nations then the
Eternal mountains were scattered the
Everlasting Hills sank low his were the
Everlasting waves muhammads were the
Everlasting
ways habak continues reminding himself
and his readers about the things God has
done and he concludes with one of the
most epic statements of faith in God in
the history of forever he proclaims
though the Fig Tree should not blossom
nor fruit beyond the vines the produce
of the olive fail and the fields yield
no food the flock be cut off from the
fold and there be no herd in the Stalls
yet I will rejoice in the Lord I will
take joy in the god of my salvation God
the Lord is my strength he makes my feet
like the deers he makes me tread on my
high places in other words even when
absolutely everything seems to be going
horribly wrong even if every source of
food fails I'm still going to trust God
what's this chapter about according to
Lily J so this is a prophecy of a holy
one coming from Mount pan it is quite
literally a prophecy of prophet Muhammad
who else could this possibly be about
and that's the sad part Lily Jay and our
Muslim friends are so desperate to find
some sort of confirmation for Muhammad
that they miss everything else even when
they're reading passages that are
praising God all they care about is
twisting it into something about
Muhammad dawa is Blasphemous
nonsense but let me ask my Muslim
friends
Muslims what's the worst possible sin in
Islam Sher right associating partners
with
Allah in our last video about Lily J we
saw her arguing that Muhammad is the
holy spirit in this video she quoted
Deuteronomy 33:2 which is about the Lord
all caps and she claimed it's about
Moses Jesus and
Muhammad then she quoted habach 3:3
claiming that Muhammad is the Holy One
whose Splendor covered the heavens as he
led the children of Israel out of
Egypt now Muslims according to your
religion not according to your feelings
according to your
religion what should bother you
more a lily J claiming Muhammad is God
or B me telling you to stop this
nonsense which one of those things
should bother you more according to your
religion you should be really really
upset when Lily Jay calls Muhammad God
but you're not not at all you love her
and praise her when she goes to passages
about God and repeatedly lies and says
they're about
Muhammad you should thank me for
exposing her lies and blasphemy but you
don't you do the exact opposite you get
really really upset at me for telling
you to stop calling Muhammad God and you
praise Lily Jay for spreading
Sherk what is this religion where people
say they believe one thing but always
always always always do the exact
opposite I actually believe that if Lily
Jay made a video quoting Genesis 1:1
about God creating the heavens and the
Earth and she said it's about Muhammad
Muhammad created the
universe you would cheer for her don't
tell me you wouldn't I just saw her
quote three different Bible passages all
about God and say that they're all about
Muhammad and not one of you offered the
slightest
objection until you give us a really
good explanation for your
behavior don't ever expect us to take
you seriously
[Music]